[Music]
so
I'm gonna talk about the last few weeks
in regards to this channel tick tock
stuff in general
uh the very short version is I put out a
video it's on YouTube in my shorts feed
and I also put it out on tick tock that
pointed out that the purchase of the
Hogwarts Legacy game is going to
contribute
and empower transphobia
because JK Rowling
benefits from every sale both
financially and also in terms of
maintained relevance attention and clout
and all of those things her wealth and
the attention that she has from eyes on
her and the cloud that she is granted by
being the Creator and owner of a
massively successful property are
currently all being wielded against
trans people particularly in the UK
where she lives
and
that
I knew there were people who wouldn't
want to hear that
I was aware of that
but honestly no matter what you might
think I wasn't trying to poke the bear
I made
what seemed like a pretty
straightforward statement
her wealth and influence is being used
to harm trans people
if you buy that game or honestly
any Harry Potter related material you
are contributing to both of those
because the maintained relevance of
Harry Potter is where her uh her clout
and the attention comes from and also
where her money comes from so that seems
like a very straightforward thing to
point out
well for the last few weeks
I have been dealing with the biggest
onslaught
of targeted Mass harassment
that I have had to deal with
in
13 or so years
uh on social media in the way that I am
so
what happened well
short version is that the uh video here
on YouTube got ratioed and is at time of
recording still being absolutely flooded
with the kinds of comments that an under
normal circumstances I would be deleting
um it is coming in so hard and so fast
and so persistently for so long I had to
do something I've actually never had to
do on YouTube before which was abandon
the comments section on that short
I normally take a lot of pride in
moderating my comment section
but at a certain point I just had to I
literally was getting nothing else done
because a normal day for me
separate from all this is
maybe on a bad day maybe a dozen
uh comments that I need to clear out
people I need to ban from being able to
comment that's at most it's probably on
a normal day more like half that
I was instead when this was going on
dealing with uh actually at the point I
abandoned it I started looking at it and
you know keeping track how quickly are
these coming in it was two to three a
minute which doesn't sound that bad
until you start running the math and
realize that if we average that out to
say two and a half a minute on average
that's 150 hateful comments that
normally I would be deleting per hour
and once we are into full days and I've
been dealing with this for
at time of recording uh about a week had
been at its worst for about three days
and could very well have continued so
after recording uh up until the upload
of this thing then we're into multiples
of thousands a day
I moderate my own comment section I have
mods for my lives but the comments I do
myself
it exceeded my bandwidth I couldn't I've
never had to abandon a comment section
before this is not my first time being
targeted but there were a lot of unique
aspects to this
but it also wasn't only YouTube Tech
talk was also flooded with hate comments
now I've been flooded with nonsense on
Tick Tock before and I I don't have uh
as much commitment to the Integrity of a
comment section on Tick Tock uh as I do
on YouTube so I've abandoned comment
sections on there before
but I also started getting repeatedly uh
reported for various false things I had
videos reported for depicting a crime
had those restored and appealed I had
videos reported for sexual conduct and
nudity I appealed those had them
restored I was temporarily banned off my
account because I was reported by
multiple people as being under the age
of 13.
I did get the account restored after
that I went through a lot of this for a
while and then eventually the account
did just flat out get banned and I I
know why it was banned but I don't know
the justification because it was banned
because it was mass reported and I feel
comfortable in saying falsely so
but exactly what the justification was I
don't know because Tick Tock won't tell
me
they told me banned for Community
violations it doesn't say what the
violations are just as Community
violations I attempted to appeal but
because they wouldn't tell me what it
was I actually did wrong I had to try
and build a defense over an accusation I
was not allowed to know
and shock my appeal was denied whether
it's because they were going to deny it
no matter what I said or because I
defended myself against the wrong
freaking thing I will never know
and so my account got killed this is
actually the second time I've had my
account killed but last time it wasn't
from targeted harassment like this was
as I said I'm very confident that it was
a mass reporting
but I don't know the rationale or the
excuse given
so that's what I've been dealing with
how is this different from crap I've
already been through because like I said
not entirely my first rodeo but this is
different
in a number of ways because the last two
times this has happened to me it has
been when videos of mine have been
specifically targeted by much larger
entities on the platforms that are on
and particularly on YouTube at the time
and then their followers would descend
specifically on those videos
um but also on my channel in general
uh first time that ever happened was
with a Creator called bearing who uh not
just on me also did it to Jackson bird
and I think somebody else as well uh
took Snippets uh out of context of
videos uh pointing out issues with at
the time uh the casting of Scarlett
Johansson as a trans man for a project
that ultimately did not move forward
with her in that part but at the time it
was very frustrating and upsetting and a
number of trans people expressed that
and Snippets were taken to make us look
irrational and uh unstable
and so his followers descended on me
the uh the other one was Blair white who
took a video off of my very wild Channel
which is a separate Channel where I
discuss a number of things
um and in particular about my existence
as a gender fluid person as well as some
product reviews and things of that
nature but uh she took a video and took
Snippets and uh decided to pull apart
the concept that I was trans without
having dysphoria which was
um the main focus of the video she
pulled from now she did a couple of
other stuff she included uh discussions
of and images of a completely different
a trans person who claims to not have
dysphoria who had apparently also
threatened her now she didn't claim I
was also that person but she also
intercut us without ever saying we were
two different people so I not only had
her fans descend uh on my channel but uh
had them to send on my channel falsely
believing
that I had threatened her when I had
well I still have literally never
interacted with her directly and had
never spoken about or even really knew
much about her before all this had
happened
it didn't matter now I couldn't actually
say that she falsely accused me of
threatening her because technically she
didn't she just cut together a very lazy
video that made it easy to assume that
but that's what I've dealt with before
the thing is both those times there was
an individual there was a specific
Creator who decided that I was a viable
Target and
tried to do something that is a takedown
of me or a position I had or otherwise
did something towards me and then their
followers came at me after that
that's not what happened with the
Hogwarts Legacy short
there I was never to the best of my
knowledge
targeted acknowledged by
uh quote tweeted or tagged
by JK Rowling or anyone involved in that
game
but I got assigned
uh the straw man of the month
regardless
it's a very odd experience
being turned into a straw man
if you're not familiar with that term
a straw man argument is where you create
an image of the of someone holding the
opposing view that you have that is
that does not need to be based on
reality uh decently constructed straw
man will have elements of reality but
you basically create an image of this is
the kind of person I'm arguing against
and then you argue against that imagined
version of a person
and it's something that happens a lot
and the severity of it and the degree of
it
it can go a lot of ways but it's a very
common thing that happens to some degree
or another pretty much anytime you ever
hear anyone talk about
the sjws
the conservatives the Liberals whatever
group
and for the audience they're talking to
they're trying to create a very specific
image
even though they are describing a group
that's a straw man
and the thing about being chosen to be a
straw man which is what happened with
this harassment campaign towards me
is that
when they've decided that you're gonna
fit their straw man narrative what you
actually did and actually said doesn't
matter
they're going to continue to rail
against the straw man version of you
not actually you
what do I mean by that well
um good example would be some of the
common uh refrains that I had in the
comments section before I had to
completely abandon it
which was that in a video where I said
this if you buy the Hogwarts Legacy game
you are contributing to transphobia I
was told that I was calling everyone who
bought that game transphobic
and I didn't
I actually was
incredibly specific with my wording in
that short there is a reason I said
contributes to transphobia and not is a
transphobe I did not say makes you a
transphobe if you do this
the closest I've ever come to saying
anything like that was in uh the video
that I did on Hollow allyship where I
pointed out that buying that game does
mean that you really shouldn't be
calling yourself an ally
but being not an ally is also not being
a transphobe
there are lots of people who are just
hanging out in the middle not really
doing either one which can still be a
problem but that's really not what I'm
getting into I never equated
you're either Ally or you're transphobe
I've never done that and in that short
I never said
buying that game makes you transphobic I
summed this all up actually rather
succinctly in a tweet a couple days ago
and simply pointing out you buy this
game you're contributing to the ability
of a transphobe to continue to hurt
trans people
and I started getting inundated
with a lot of nonsense including death
threats and encouragements of self-harm
and
when I pointed that out I did quite
literally
especially on tick tock
uh because I did start a new account and
they immediately found me again which
means that there's probably a Discord
server somewhere passing my information
around it I guess but
they even the people who acknowledged
the death threats
that was with a sentiment that included
well you shouldn't have called people
bigots
you shouldn't have called people
transphobes
it was my fault for getting death
threats
for saying something
I did not say
but that's what the straw man version
of me said and their minds that's what I
said because in their minds
I was not the person in that video
that's why so many of the comments that
I'm still getting say things like cry
harder stay mad
I'm not crying in that video
I don't raise my voice I'm smiling
at the end of that thing
I wasn't mad
I wasn't crying
but they didn't see this
they saw this
because that's what they wanted me to be
that's the straw man they decided I was
it's hard to know
how long
this will last I imagine or I hope
that within a week or two of the release
of Hogwarts Legacy when just the nature
of the limited attention span of uh the
culture people will move on to the next
hotness but the thing is
that thing I said casually a few minutes
ago I bet you my name is getting moved
around in Discord servers somewhere or
some other manner in a way that I can't
be certain of
and I'm fairly confident in that because
of how quickly they found my second
account because like I especially on
Tick Tock I've just had the algorithm do
me dirty I've just had the algorithm to
put my stuff in front of people who
you know didn't want to see it and they
weren't my audience and
they were mean to me
and while that's not great that is just
a thing that happens but when that
happens
when you make a new account
the algorithm is basically wiped clean
you're not suddenly going to be put back
in front of the same people again they
had to find me and they found me
immediately which meant they were
looking for me
which means that they were
to some degree coordinated
I don't think there's any more
coordination than there's some
transphobic Discord somewhere that's
like hey she made a new account get her
I don't think it's anything more than
that I don't think anyone's plotting in
a war room I don't think I matter that
much but I'm on a list of viable targets
now among some of these people
and
what that means is while I expect this
will die down uh in a matter of a few
weeks
my uh accounts will probably be targeted
again
whenever a major piece of Harry Potter
is on the horizon or coming out and
here's a fun additional thing that's
happened since I shot this apparently
somebody found my FetLife profile and
decided to be real cute to try and
threaten me with that fact which on the
one hand is kind of funny with how
stupid it is yes I have sexuality for
crying out loud it's publicly known I
have an only fans are you really
thinking you can shame me with that but
on the other hand actually actively
pisses me off because they're also
threatening my partners in this so yeah
they are uh trying to dig up anything
they can which probably means that this
is gonna last a bit longer than I
predicted yeah hey
because
this is a recurrent thing
for people who have been
targeted
by these sorts of groups these sorts of
outlets by things like gamergate
they don't
lose the lists of names of people that
it's that they decided it was okay to
harass they keep those names and they go
back to them
and so
if I'm lucky
I'll be considered a low enough priority
that it won't be
this massive again
but part of the intent of this is to
silence me
to get me to delete that video
to get me to say I misspoke I didn't
as I said I chose my words
very carefully I did not misspeak and I
stand by what I said
and
they want me silenced
they want me to flee or they want to be
able to shut me down which on Tick Tock
they did
and I don't even think
it's for any reason other than
this is a reflexive Instinct from a
certain circle of yes transphobes but
also just
Edge Lords
just trolls
it's a mix and it's hard to parse how
many of these people genuinely
have distinct animosity for me and how
many of them are just
jumping in on a harassment campaign
because that's their idea of fun
I don't know
I'll never know
it doesn't really matter
the thing is I know I've only gotten a
taste
of what so many people
queer people trans people
women people of color
fat people
disabled people
members of all these groups are targeted
for harassment on a regular basis
and I know that while this is the worst
I've had to deal with
it is a fraction of what people even
dear friends of mine have dealt with
my friend Jesse gender
was
specifically targeted by JK Rowling was
tagged
by her and when that happened it waved a
signal flag for everyone who is either a
fan of JK Rowling or is piggybacking
offer statements as an excuse to harass
people because again they think it's fun
they went after her
she's a very close friend of mine
she's my podcast co-host and I know she
had it worse than I have had it I can
only begin to imagine
what some other people have gone through
not just in things relating to JK
Rowling but things like gamergate as I
said
these
campaigns of harassment
be they spontaneous or organized
they are depressingly a fact of life on
the internet
which is not a reason to just be like ah
what are you gonna do no it's
messed up something should happen
exactly what I don't know
step one for me is
remaining visible
I'm fortunate enough to have been on
YouTube long enough to have some degree
of standing here some degree of clout
Tick Tock don't care
Tick Tock doesn't give a crap I'm
a very fortunate person
and I know that
the fact that I get to do this for my
living
is an amazing privilege
and it's a privilege that a certain
stripe of person wants to turn into a
nightmare
in the hope that I will go away
and they won't have to hear me point out
that
buying official Harry Potter products
contributes to transphobia
that's it
that was what I said
they don't want to hear it
and the people who don't want to hear it
come in all flavors
from the people who will debate the
premise
and fight the very concept that JK
Rowling is transphobic usually quoting
things from her from what she said two
and a half years ago and ignoring
anything she said in the last two years
or you know paying attention to the full
meaning of what she said
there are the people who simply claim
that
you know you can't tell me what to do
there are people who try and
twist it so that I am a harm to the
trans Community because I make them look
stupid
I'm sure the straw man version of me
does
but I stand by what I said
and then there's those who flatly wish
me harm
who talk about wanting to play that game
and to use Avada Kedavra on trans people
which is not how the game is designed to
work by the way it's single player it's
not multiplayer but uh the point is
that
whatever rationale people would have
it was rare for it to be presented
without a side serving of abuse
whether they argue that my suggestion
that pirating is at least more
acceptable than buying the game outright
is somehow uh a moral failing on my part
that would also include
stains on my character and name-calling
and threats
whether it be you can't tell me what to
do it we would be accompanied with shut
the [__] up
none of these arguments would ever be
presented without abuse without
excessive capitalizations without
exclamation points
without slurs
some of them would
not a lot it's just what my
laughs life trying to do my job has been
for weeks now and the fact that even
those who
can bring it upon themselves to say okay
you shouldn't have gotten death threats
but and then they have something to say
after that but
oh and let me be clear about something
nobody should be getting harassed
not me
not rolling
now people streaming this stupid [__]
game
I don't do it
I don't condone it and I shouldn't have
to condemn it
it is not my job
to denounce the actions of [__]
just to clarify what I'm talking about
here the current narrative is that trans
activists are harassing bullying and
shouting at streamers who are streaming
the game and causing them to cry or
leave their streams or what have you for
as many stories as I see run about this
harassment they all seem to cite the
exact same incident an incident from
which the most widely circulated clip
does not show the chat but yes it is
still possible it has happened while
harassment is not okay ever why exactly
am I asked to denounce the handful of
incidents that appear to have happened
I'm expected to announce this while
other people tell me that I brought the
harassment I'm suffering onto myself
I'd ask you to make it make sense but it
never will so don't bother so this is
not a call to action
nor was the short
the short wasn't even a boycott I'd
never said the word boycott the point
was never
to actually make the dev Studio go
bankrupt or to financially starve JK
Rowling that was never going to happen
I knew that
it was a request to take into
consideration the impact of your
purchasing choice and to consider at
least one other viable option that's
what it was but you wouldn't know that
from the comments
to look at the comments you would assume
that with tears in my eyes I screamed
anyone who buys this game is transphobic
because that's the version of me
that they responded to
despite the fact that it didn't exist
when that video first went up I was
replying to some of the bad faith
pushback I was pointing out I didn't
actually say that
but even before the absolute flood of
hate comments came in I gave up trying
to do that because
I realize they don't care what I
actually said it never mattered what I
actually said
that's part of what getting ratioed is
it is drowning out the original voice
with something else
maybe depending on the nature of the
ratio with a correction
with a logical fallacy or maybe it's
drowning It Out by painting over
an absurd screeching caricature
of a woke sjw
and Plastering that over a human being
acting as if that's who I was and that's
who I am
and trying to bend
people's perception so that everyone
would treat me that way at the very
least in the comments sections of that
video
but it's not who I am
I know who I am
more to the point I know that you don't
and so with that knowledge
I move forward
and if you bought that game I hope you
enjoyed it
I actually mean that sincerely it would
really suck that you put money that went
towards uh someone who is doing as much
damage as JK Rowling is doing you didn't
even get a good game out of it that
would actually be kind of crap if you
got it I hope you enjoyed it
the impact is still what I said it was
doesn't make you a transphobe
it doesn't make you my enemy
depending on how well you are acquainted
with the situation it may make you
someone who has chosen
to
not do the simple Act of failing to buy
a thing in order to support trans people
I mean maybe some people probably aren't
aware they're still contributing
that's a notion makes people so angry
truth hurts
the thing is I don't have a big platform
if I told a lie you could just ignore me
and move on if I told us if I truly told
the self-evident LIE
you wouldn't have to shout me down
because people wouldn't listen
I'm not anybody of note
I'm barely known within the Doctor Who
freaking community
but if you know what I say has truth to
it
there's a reason to shout that down
there's a reason to drown that out
and that's the thing about all these
comments All saying the exact same thing
it's not about actually confronting what
I said it's about drowning it out and in
the comment section of that video I
suppose they did but in terms of me
going forward day to day no
still here
still trans
look at that I didn't shut up I almost
said sorry
but no
I love to talk
I'm lucky enough to do it for a job
and I'm gonna keep doing it
and thank you for listening to me talk
if you want to support what I do patreon
is the best way to do so that is the
most reliable form of income that I have
uh YouTube is a little bit more erratic
and uh you'll also find a lovely
community of people on the patreon
there's a patreon exclusive Discord
amongst other uh perks consider that
but even if you can't other things that
I do you can follow down in the
description
but uh
don't worry too much about that leave
your comments let me know what you
thought be respectful do not harass me
or other commenters
But ultimately what I really want you to
remember is that
even as we go through all this
you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings best as I can despite the
riffraff
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore zoom
in lafolla to rock the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Melinda
Walters emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky
Sparks for nobilax the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support and if you want
to get your name in the credits check
out the rewards on the patreon
[Music]
foreign